[Música]
bom pessoal queria começar em 2016
voltar um pouco no tempo
a câmara dos deputados brasília estatuto
da família 6 todo mundo lembra não
trouxe um vídeo que vai refrescar um
pouco a memória foi aprovado hoje uma
comissão especial da câmara o estatuto
da família como núcleo formado a partir
da união europa
então essa é a definição oficial de
família do congresso nacional
esse vídeo e causa um pouco de vergonha
mesmo acho que a palavra que eu posso
usar principalmente quando ele grita
viva família porque a família que ele
estava ali comemorando essa indefinição
aqui
o núcleo formado a partir da união entre
um homem e uma mulher
antigo né daqui a pouco a gente volta
nesse assunto
eu queria trazer para vocês uma história
muito pessoal
eu sou casado com renata a gente tem um
filho arthur lindo por sinal é o artur é
muito ligado na palavra família desde
muito pequeno renata sempre filho que a
família para você quem a sua família
ele falava o papai a mamãe e uma lei
porque a gente tem um cachorro também o
mali
então ele se importava mais na família
do lado da gente no apartamento do lado
tem uma outra família
jorge o carlos eo bruninho que eles
adotaram recentemente o menino já mais
velho com a diferença
o jorge o bruninho e o carlos fazem as
mesmas coisas que fazemos eu a renata eo
artur
segundo o estatuto da família eles não
são uma família mas nós somos porque
sabe que aqui é pior
tem muita gente que concorda com isso
muita muita mesmo eu acho que nessa
época ficou claro o quanto as pessoas de
que o país estava muito dividido né como
a gente está até hoje
e muita gente concorda com essa
definição mas tem muita gente que não
concorda nem eu trabalho numa agência de
comunicação no rio a nbs uma grande
agência
o nosso trabalho é exatamente esse
antenado sabendo das coisas que estão
acontecendo no mundo no país no rio de
janeiro
é o que nossos clientes pedem da gente e
foi ali no calor do estatuto da família
das pessoas discutindo sobre nas redes
sociais que o igor um dos nossos
planejadores decidiu botar no google
definição da palavra família e aí foi
que apareceu um grupo de pessoas vivendo
sob o mesmo teto
especialmente o pai a mãe e os filhos
antigo né
o google uma empresa super hi pada super
pra frente
uma empresa diferente das outras ainda
tinha essa definição
e foi isso que chamou muita atenção da
gente a gente juntou um grupo grande lá
na agência de pessoas que se
interessavam pelo tema e decidimos mudar
a palavra no google parece difícil é
estranho pois vão mudar a palavra no
como é que vão fazer isso a gente também
não sabia como é que nem por onde
começar
a gente criou um projeto chamado todas
as famílias
não sei se vou ver a carinha para ver se
vocês conseguem reconhecer espero que
alguém lembre dele é um pouco do que a
gente vai trazer aqui hoje
então a gente o que a gente queria ali a
gente queria juntar fazer uma palavra
família ser mais atual
a gente queria que a palavra família
fosse mais abrangente que ela pegasse a
minha família mas pegar essa família do
meu vizinho também porque eles não são
família
então a gente criou esse projeto e e e
de cara já vem o primeiro problema a
primeira dificuldade
aquela palavra do google não é uma
palavra do google não é uma palavra da
empresa americana
aquela palavra eles tiraram um
dicionário ficou mais difícil
agora a gente tinha que mudar a palavra
no dicionário mas a gente não desistiu
batemos na porta de um dicionário
batemos na porta de outro agente no
final acabou sendo até melhor não sei se
a gente deu sorte
a gente chegou no instituto antônio
houaiss que é quem publica o grande
dicionário houaiss que é um dos maiores
do país que depois inclusive a gente
descobriu
é de onde o google tira as definições
dele e eles toparam eles gostaram do
nosso projeto eles também achavam que a
palavra antiga eo pessoal do rapaz
embarcou com a gente nessa aventura por
isso que eu falei que acabou sendo até
melhor
então no modelo normal de de trabalho
deles que seria mais fácil a gente
passaria o briefing para eles é o
lexicógrafo também não sabe o que quer é
o cara que queria as palavras da a
descrição das palavras do dicionário o
lexicógrafo criaria a palavra família a
gente correr em um outro risco dela
continua não sendo tão inclusiva quanto
a gente gostaria que fosse a gente
queria um projeto que trouxesse opiniões
do brasil inteiro que as pessoas
pudessem opinar contar suas idéias como
é que eram suas famílias
eles toparam eles gostaram embarcaram
com a gente mais uma vez a gente lançou
um vídeo onde funcionava assim a gente
criou um site um site super bonito onde
as pessoas podiam mandar seus vídeos
contando suas histórias das suas
famílias ou apenas mandar uma foto
mandar um texto contando ou sobre você
mesmo ou sobre o que você julgava ser
família
queremos um vídeo que viralizou criamos
uma hashtag vamos influenciadores a
gente usou todo nosso poder de
comunicação da agência usamos
influenciadores usamos artistas
fizemos a notícia se espalhar pelo país
e deu certo a gente recebeu mais de três
mil definições de família tanto no site
quanto nas redes sociais
e aí o que a gente precisava fazer a
gente estava juntar tudo isso e
transformar numa palavra eu trouxe
algumas definições aqui pra vocês verem
um pouquinho do que as pessoas mandaram
toda a família nasce do amor se alimenta
do amor tudo está baseado no amor é uma
frase do emílio que é casado com sérgio
eles são os pais do samuel e da lula eu
e ela
meu tio namorado dele minha mãe solteira
meu pai casado meu avô viúva namorando
todos são família
famílias são pessoas ligadas por laços
de afeto amor responsáveis uns pelos
outros
independente de gênero número ou grau
duas ou mais pessoas que optam por
manter uma relação de afeto e contato ao
longo de suas vidas muito diferente
daquela frase que a gente viu no início
né
eu queria aproveitar aqui pra contar pra
vocês um pouquinho da minha relação um
com as pessoas que participaram do
projeto porque no início no primeiro
vídeo que a gente fez
a gente teve realmente teve contato a
gente teve relação com as pessoas que eu
conheci duas famílias incríveis
a primeira do seu salvador lá na agência
também faz parte do projeto social da
agência a gente tem um escritório numa
favela no rio
no santa marta e lá a gente ficou por
cinco anos
a gente não tem mais o escritório mas a
escola por cinco anos
eu conheci pessoas incríveis pessoas que
não estão no meu círculo de amizades e
onde eu aprendi muito nessa convivência
o seu salvador é esse aqui ele é pai e
avô e bisavô vive com 21 pessoas dentro
de casa
neto bisneto no fim não tem de tudo
a dona neusa que a esposa dele a dona
neusa diferente do pessoal de brasília
acha que família é isso aqui eu quero
estar com eles em todos os momentos da
minha vida nos momentos bons e nos
momentos ruins mas o importante é
estarmos todos juntos sempre acho que eu
prefiro acreditar na dona neusa do que
nele né
outra família que eu queria trazer para
vocês é da bianca e da renata sabia que
a renata tons ficaram juntos durante 13
anos até decidirem ter o primeiro filho
elas tentaram uma vez tentaram outra até
que a bianca através de inseminação
artificial teve uma filha a valentina a
bianca hoje inclusive trabalha na
agência e de vez em quando valentina vai
lá ela já está maior e um pouco brinca
cabeça com a gente depois a renata
resolveu fazer inseminação artificial e
vieram as duas meninas
alina e ana essas limpezas e aí dá pra
dizer que isso não é uma família
acho que não né então o que eu trouxe
esses dois exemplos para vocês porque eu
acho que conversar com essas pessoas
entender a realidade delas se somou a
tudo aquilo que a gente recebeu via rede
social através da hashtag do brasil
inteiro e deixou a equipe da rbs e eu
estou aqui conversando com vocês
deixa a gente mais pronto mais apto para
fazer o que a gente queria porque não é
fácil a gente mudar a definição de uma
palavra né então quem somos nós pra
fazer isso então eu acho que esses
exemplos trazem um pouco do do porquê
que a gente se sentiu tranqüilo para
poder fazer isso e aí que a gente fez a
gente reuniu todas essas informações que
chegaram novas definições o que a gente
aprendeu
juntamos tudo enviamos para o instituto
antônio houaiss aí sim
agora com as informações do brasil
inteiro eles poderiam juntar à equipe
deles que tem além do lexicógrafo outros
profissionais para fazer essa nova
definição e até que nem demorou muito em
sei lá
dois meses mais ou menos eles mandaram
lá pra agência nova definição nós foi
incrível assim é ali materializado o
resultado do nosso trabalho a gente
sonhou com aquilo e aquela entrega foi o
que a gente achou até que não ia
acontecer
eles mandaram pra gente essa nova
definição núcleo social de pessoas
unidas por laços afetivos que geralmente
compartilham o mesmo espaço e mantêm
entre si uma relação solidária bem mais
legal né do que aquela primeira que eu
mostrei lá na frente
bem mais abrangente bem mais
acho que representa mais que a gente
veio de família por aí ea gente tinha
uma beleza a gente conseguiu mudar
como é que a gente faz chegar às pessoas
né e eu acho que era tão importante
quanto a gente conseguiu
a palavra para a gente conseguir fazer
chegar ao maior número de pessoas
possível ea gente fez uma reportagem no
fantástico que foi aquela que passou
antes e durante a semana a gente colocou
em todos os jornais todos os sites todos
os tv e na rede social
e foi muito bem recebida e se nova essa
nova definição
as pessoas gostaram muito é claro que
quando a gente joga na rede social hoje
em dia aparece de tudo né
e de cara aparecer um jeito eu não
contei lá atrás mas logo que a gente
lançou o site eles tentaram derrubar o
nosso site inclusive ea gente tomando
decisão que eu achei sábia que foi de
ignorar quem vinha com violência com
grosseria enfim a gente ouviu quem era
contrário ao que o site se propunha
porque a gente tinha que ouvir todas as
partes mas os reitores quem vinha com
violência a gente achou melhor evitar
porque eu tô falando deles porque eu
acho que é fã contemporânea né a gente
precisava tá no momento certo no lugar
certo no tacho que o time é muito
importante quando a gente trabalha na
agência a gente é muito preocupado com a
questão de time
dez anos antes em 2006
a gente nunca teria conseguido fazer o
que a gente fez é um assunto que as
pessoas nem pensavam em falar família
falou de família antigamente era um
negócio ninguém podia encostar nisso ea
gente aproveitou o momento aproveitou a
discussão aproveitou que era super
contemporâneo e que as pessoas estavam
falando sobre e que é o congresso estava
falando e conseguimos mudar a definição
de família
é a gente mudou o estatuto não não
mudamos está tudo mas acho que não
interessa que eles pensam em brasília
acho que é muito mais legal do que as
pessoas pensam eu queria trazer para
vocês um aí um relato pessoal né
eu sou branco eu sou heterossexual
eu sou não tem motivos pra sofrido
preconceito na vida
eu acho até que durante grande parte da
minha vida eu fui machista
sem saber então esse projeto mudou muita
gente brasil afora e mudou
principalmente eu mesmo
eu aprendi muito
conhecendo as famílias ouvindo suas
histórias
aprendi muito com tudo que as pessoas
mandaram eu acho que o projeto teve
trouxe pra minha vida particular duas
coisas muito importante uma ter
conseguido mudar uma palavra no
dicionário algo que nunca imaginei que
fosse possível de se fazer ea outra eu
acho que todas as famílias foi uma uma
aula
foi uma aula do que eu precisava pra
minha vida eu aprendi muito com ela
é isso obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]